uh hey Neil does time move faster at the
expanding edge of the universe and
slower at the center I don't know you
might have to talk
first of all the center part and I don't
know
however I love the question in terms of
the expanding Edge okay here's something
interesting
if you're moving away from me right in
an expanding Universe right and you have
a clock that's ticking seconds okay if I
watch that clock
consecutive seconds that I observe will
come to me more and more delayed right
okay so when I observe you it will look
like you have slowed down right but as
far as you're concerned you're just
running that's right that's right so
when she talked about the expanding Edge
if you're gonna watch that edge you will
see things slow down in that place right
but it's not an actual Edge right it's
not a physical Edge it's just a it's a
horizon where you that's all that is if
you go to that edge now you're in the
middle of a New Horizon that is itself
whatever distance away it would need to
be once you if you did the math on that
right so if any the way to answer that
is if you want to make any of that true
is the opposite of what she said you'd
be observing objects evolve more slow
slowly on the edge the expanding Edge
and you a relative to you that's pretty
dope I gotta say I like that all right
do you think it's possible we'll find
complex organisms like fish in the
liquid water masses in the planets and
moons of he says our souls yeah okay so
first a fish is a way complex organism
right generally when biologists speak of
complex organisms they're not talking
about fish right they're talking about
multicellular creatures that have might
have some appendages like at the
Cambrian explosion of life when was that
450 500 million years ago we went from
single-celled creatures rapidly when the
conditions changed on Earth to
multicellular life and that
multicellular life had like Limbs and
eyes and and it had features okay that
you could talk about and point to right
generally we call that complex life I
want to find life in the oceans beneath
the Frozen surfaces of the moons of
Jupiter and Saturn and I want there to
be life there but it's not only if
there's water there right okay I just
want to get thermodynamic on you okay
okay go for it all right as far as we
know whatever life is it will require
metabolism okay right it'll have to
process energy in some way okay
for it to process energy in its
environment there has to be a place that
has more energy than in another place
so that there's energy flow so life does
not happen without a transference of
energy correct and the technically you
call that an energy gradient okay okay
so that's what you need all right and so
under there there's sources of energy
from like the gravitational stress from
Jupiter and from Saturn and other moons
on those moons and that pumps energy
like deep in the center and so so no if
it's hotter in the center than in the
edge then we're good so you mean the
gravitational
forces of the planet that this moon is
orbiting yes causes the tidal forces
causes an undulation yes that creates
energy heat yes like when you bend a
paper clip back and forth back and forth
a better example would be when they say
if you're going to play racquetball
let's warm up the ball and what are you
doing you hits the ball you squeeze in
and puffs back up because every time
deformation and a restoration and every
time you do that you're pumping energy
into the ball from your racket that's
what's going on to those moons right now
all right that's that's dude that's dope
that's really and the hottest moon in
the solar system yeah is called IO and
it's closest moon to Jupiter right and
it's feeling this ferociously and it's
got the most ferocious volcanoes that
everywhere because hot in the middle the
stuff has got to get out and it's it's
hurling and that is that is
basically from Gravity that's that's
gravity gravity stress yes stress of
gravity pumping it and it's by the way
it's outside of the Goldilocks zone
right so we used to think oh you need
the Sun and it's got to be just right
and no you just need energy right all
right there you go and I just love
science
all right what do you think unlocking
the secrets of Dark Matter could do for
us scientifically would it lead us to
being able to harness it wow those are
two really big questions
how old is he is he some kid in a
basement trying to he's trying to figure
something a superhero Nemesis in the
making we have no idea what dark matter
is I have my own preferences but my
preferences don't matter what matters is
what experiments are active and in
progress and right now the going
thinking is that it is a category of
particle that simply doesn't interact
with us electromagnetically so
electromagneticism is like light and
magnetism and all the things that make
atoms stick together as molecules so you
are held together by electromagnetic
forces all right that's why and therapy
twice a week this would be a category of
particles that does not interact with
our electromagnetic forces which means
they just pass right on through like
you're not even there right but so they
need to observe something like that
gravitationally
okay so we only know the only reason why
we know there's Dark Matter here is
because well we have some galaxies but
add up all the matter in those galaxies
it doesn't account for what's going on
in this part of the neighborhood because
you see galaxies from behind whose light
gets lensed according to Einstein's
general relativity and you can ask how
much mass does it take how much gravity
does it take to lens by that amount and
you come up with a number way bigger
than simply counting the the galaxies
that are there right something else is
happening so we call it dark matter
because we don't know what else to call
it like I said I've said many times it's
really dark gravity right it's literally
dark rabbit right we don't know if it's
matter the folks betting on it think it
is matter and there's a new kind of
particle that we have yet to isolate
that's all that's what that so all right
if we do isolate it okay what would you
do with it or you put it in your hand no
it'll pass right through your hand
because it doesn't interact with your
hand all right so I don't know how you
would contain it how do you contain it
you need something that interacts not
only with our forces but also with its
forces that could be yet another
Frontier of Discovery in the universe
what is that intermediary thing if you
were that Civilization right you'd be
badass oh my gosh you control not only
all the universe that we know about
right but the rest of the universe
that's influenced by Dark Matter you'd
be able to grab it make dark matter
planets out of it you can make it stick
to itself so yeah that would be a
powerful posture to pervey all right can
you explain to us Immortal language how
the boson gives Mass to matter oh so how
does Higgs work that's a lot so you need
to think of mass not as mass in the
traditional sense and not in this
explanation think of it as inertia okay
so inertia in common parlance is the
tendency of something to want to stay in
motion but it's also the opposite of
that or the inverse of that it's the
tendency of something to not want to
move it to stay at rest okay right okay
so inertia is whatever the thing's doing
that's what he wants to keep doing
that's it all right that's it okay I'm
inertia okay lazy so you can measure the
mass of something by finding a way to
measure the inertia that it wields okay
so now watch let's go to Hollywood all
right and we're going to a Hollywood
party pick an actor who like no one has
heard of that you know of Chuck nice
if you go to a Hollywood party and
nobody knows you you can just go
straight to the bar like that if you are
famous and you walk into the party
everyone gathers around you they want
your autograph they want to take your
picture and you're working towards the
bar but you're moving really slow you
have a lot of inertia think of it as the
party field okay okay the party field is
giving Mass to the particles moving
through it gotcha okay that party field
is like because this is
right at the Higgs field is like they're
like the party goers
okay right so you got that so so if you
the more famous you are the slower you
can move through a crowd because
everybody wants a piece of you right all
right so in that way Beyonce has a very
high party Mass you have a very low
party Mass correct and everything to get
everybody else in between gotcha so
that's kind of what the Higgs field is
doing it is the resistance of two
movement of the particles that pass
through it that grants particles its
mass but it's not most of the mass of
the universe most of the mass in atoms
comes from the force fields inside the
atom not from the particles themselves
wow binding energy of the of the atoms
so so yes it gives Mass to quarks and
electrons and this sort of thing yes the
total mass of everything in the universe
is not represented by the Higgs field
it's just the particles within that are
out there well that's all really good
stuff man I hope that clears
[Laughter]
[Music]